Hey, YouTube. It's BTS week
at "The Tonight Show."
And every day, we're bringing you
incredible new performances
from the group.
Here now to perform the hit song
"Mikrokosmos,"
from their 2019 album
"Map of the Soul: Persona,"
BTS.
Shining starlight
Flashing lights on the building
We're shining
In our own rooms
On our own stars
Some lights are ambition
Some lights are wandering
The lights of people
All the precious ones
Dark night (Don't be lonely)
Like stars (We're shining)
Don't vanish
You mean a lot to me
Let us shine
The reason that the face of this night
is so beautiful
May not be
those stars or lights, but us
You got me
I'm dreaming when I look at you
I got you
In pitch-dark nights
Each other's lights we saw
We were saying the same words
More shining starlight
in the deepest night
as the night goes on
One history for one
One star for one
7 billion kinds of lights are shining
in 7 billion kinds of world
7 billion kinds of lives
The night view of the city
may be the night of another city
Dreams of each one, let us shine
You're shining more than anyone
One
The reason that the face of this night
is so beautiful
May not be the darkness
or moonlight, but us
You got me
I'm dreaming when I look at you
I got you
In pitch-dark nights
Each other's lights we saw
We were saying the same words
More shining starlight
in the deepest night
as the night goes on
The light of this city
The star of this city
I remember the night sky
I looked up when I was little
Right here,
full of lights and stars as people
We shinin'
You got me
When I look at you, I'm breathing
I got you
In pitch-dark nights
Shine, dream, smile
Oh, let us light up the night
We shine all we want
Shine, dream, smile
Oh, let us light up the night
We shine through
Tonight
We love you!
Love you!